you guys back in sin city here for the
acm awards how's it feel oh it feels
really good yeah i feel like you know
this is sort of the the demographic kind
of of our show and uh we're getting a
lot of love here tonight it feels really
good well season five of yellowstone
starts shooting soon are you guys ready
are you excited have you seen the script
yet
no scripts but we're we're really ready
it's about time so yeah we haven't shot
i think like it's like 18 months now so
i really miss everyone it's good to see
her tonight but you know we miss our our
crew and our our little tv family you
know and you're gonna have a prosthetic
baby bump to look forward to what are
your thoughts going into that oh my
goodness let's go honey i'm ready for
like i'm also ready to have a sweet
little baby on set oh yeah
do you think monica would
let casey just go back to the
yellowstone ranch once a new baby is
involved with all the drama
and violence there i know i'm telling
you it's really not easy being married
to dunton
but um you know i mean i think i mean
it's family first for her but i think
she's also starting to
to fight for what she wants as well well
we are looking forward to see what
happens luke i have to ask you you're
here in the country music space have you
been able to work on country music that
last time i talked to you you wanted to
dip your toes into it i'm not saying
anything to you
because you caused a big problem
you're always playing music
can we see casey sing more on
yellowstone can we see casey just sing
on yellowstone that would be weird if
casey started singing but you'll you'll
i think it
here pretty soon you'll you'll see luke
singing oh oh this is great yeah
that wasn't a problem i was i was
actually kind of you know it all worked
out in the end but uh
the lips are sealed right now and all
that yeah how does it feel though to be
around the country music family because
that's what it is it's a country music
family country music is you know what i
grew up on it's a it's a big part of my
life
uh it's it's so nice to be here but and
to have people know who i am here which
is strange and crazy and amazing and
then just so happy to be you know part
of this little family too who's came up
to you i know there's a lot of famous
fans of yellowstone
uh tonight so far just the midland boys
but i know them already so we'll we'll
see we'll i'll get back
i'll get back to you later about that
yeah listen when you do have music
out whenever that may be let us know
we'd love to do something special with
you
and do it on your terms and do it right
okay sounds good